Speaker 1: Welcome to The David Pakman Show,
I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire, sitting
in for David Pakman today, and might I also
say happy reinstatement week, right?
Because coming up at the end of this week,
August 13th, isn't that the day that the conspiracy
theorists tell us Donald Trump might be reinstated
as president?
So, you know, I guess we have that to look
forward to as well.
Of course, Mike Lyndell, my pillow CEO, who
David had a wonderful interview with this
past week.
If you haven't seen it, please check it out.
He had originally said August 13th could be
the day he has since kicked the can down the
road a little bit, maybe in September.
He tells us maybe it's even after that.
Who the heck knows at this point?
But one thing is for certain.
The Department of Homeland Security is certainly
taking all of this very seriously.
Late last week, the Department of Homeland
Security actually sent out notices to state
and local law enforcement offices throughout
the country.
That said, this DHS is providing awareness
of reports regarding an increasing but modest
level of activity online, calling for violence
in response to unsubstantiated claims of fraud
related to the 2020 election and the alleged
reinstatement of former President Trump.
As public visibility of the narrative increases,
we are concerned about more calls to violence.
Reporting indicates that the timing of these
activities may occur during August 20 21,
although we lack information on specific plots
or planned actions.
So Homeland Security says right now and they've
been saying this for a couple months, in case
you haven't been following that story, listen,
we have seen what these individuals are capable
of.
We saw it on January 6th when they get worked
into a frenzy based on lies and misinformation.
We've seen what they're capable of doing and
over the months since January 6th.
They have been pushing this conspiracy that
somehow, some way Trump's going to get reinstated,
so what happens when that doesn't happen?
See, that's what they're worried about, is
what happens when the conspiracy theory proves
to be totally false.
Right.
Trump is not going to be reinstated as president
on August 13th or at any time unless he wins
a future election.
And that's not reinstatement.
That's winning an election.
But either way, people are going to be angry.
People who have been led to believe these
things, we don't know how they're going to
react, and that is what Department of Homeland
Security is saying, they have seen what they
believe to be threats of violence online.
However, there's been no specific indication
of where, when, how or even really if it's
going to happen.
You know, a threat is one thing.
An actual plan is a totally different thing.
And Homeland Security is just basically telling
everybody be on the ready.
And that's a terrifying thought, right?
We don't want to have to live our lives with
this kind of fear of what's going to happen
when the Trump people don't get their way,
when these cultists realize that their conspiracy
theories are totally false, we shouldn't have
to live with that.
But unfortunately, right now, this is a reality
that far too many of us well, not far too
many, all of us have to accept.
Here's another thing, too, and I've talked
about this in videos on my other channels,
but you also have the judges, OK, the people
hearing the cases, listening to these defendants
who were arrested as part of the January 6th
capital riot.
And the judges have flat out told us.
These individuals learn nothing.
These individuals are likely to do this again
because the same kind of lies and misinformation
that got these people worked up in the first
place, they're still out there.
And these judges are trained through years
and years of experience to recognize what
a so-called repeat offender looks like.
They look at the psychology, they look at
the behavior, they look at mannerisms, for
God's sake.
And they see it, as they have told us, with
some of these individuals.
And we've also had at least one judge come
out and say, I'm afraid these people are getting
off too lightly for what they actually did
that day and therefore will definitely not
learn a lesson.
And these are people we're going to have to
keep watching because they're likely to do
it again.
And that's what Homeland Security is trying
to tell us.
Now, nobody wants to live in a police state,
trust me.
But they're concerned that what happens this
weekend when Trump doesn't get reinstated
could be very bad for the country, and if
you don't
believe
that these people
are actively organizing, then take
a look at
this story.